hey guys
welcome to part two of my q a
i only intended to do one of these
videos
uh but all of you sent in so many good
questions
that i just felt obliged to keep reading
them and uh well i hope you find this
interesting
this might be a good way to start lucas
wang asks
brief summary of your journey as a
musician and how you ended up with a
career you have today
it's obviously a long story but i'm
happy to give you it in a
in a nutshell uh i started i started
playing electric guitar when i was 11.
um and i played in a bunch of rock bands
until you know throughout high school
and early college
but then i went to college for recording
and
sound recording and classical guitar but
then
i ended up liking classical guitar and
more so i ended up doing two degrees in
classical guitar and while i did those
i ended up going to an early music
festival and i had an actual you know
loot and baroque guitar and fjorbo put
in my hand
and i just was you know from there on
out i was
obsessed with the idea of playing you
know instruments that were popular
hundreds of years ago i thought that was
just
amazing so um yeah so i
before i knew it i started buying loots
and you know trying to learn bro guitar
and all these instruments
and the second i had them i was started
being booked for
four gigs and so before i knew it i just
kind of was thrown in the rabbit hole of
the early music scene and um kept
playing concerts and liking the music
more and more
and so here i am oh no
make orwell fiction again writes what
was your worst
gig i can think of a few
but probably hands down the winner was
the time that i agreed
to play a dog funeral it was very sad
actually but uh not not the most
artistically rewarding gig
i've ever had james writes did people
ever mention your long nails or think it
was weird or gross
whenever i go out in public i feel as
though my nails make me
seem like i neglect basic hygiene in
even though i just like to play guitar
hey man i feel your pain um
yeah you know that's something that we
all have to get through as classical
guitarist if you
if you have nails um i've definitely
been on
you know a subway or two when i have my
hand on the railing and somebody else is
going to put their hand there and they
see my nails and
uh you know you get that look of huh and
uh
the funny thing about that is one thing
to have long nails but then they
if they see that on your left hand you
you have short nails
now they're just like totally confused
you know because like
they can't think of why would anyone do
that anyway uh you know i think you
explain to people that it's your art
form you know it's what you do
um to express yourself musically and now
it becomes
you know instead of having this you know
hygienic problem
you have this uh skill that you have
cultivated i think it can become
actually a really interesting point of
conversation
all right jab writes who were your
favorite rock bands during your young
shredding days
um that's an easy one to answer because
i had just like a few that i was
obsessed with and more you know like
metal band shirts every day
throughout high school um iron maiden
and metallica those were the two that i
listened to
everything every seater they had and i
could play through
several metallica cds on my curcamic
guitar
this next one is a really important
question pravin writes
did your hand ever start tingling while
playing guitar and you got scared so
much that you thought you could
stop playing after years of practice yes
this happened to me i had a whole
experience and i'm still somewhat
involved in
fixing this hand issue that i had so i
had some tingling and then i eventually
had
a lot of tension and my hand felt like a
rock
and i still if i don't do a good job
with stretching and maintaining my
you know technical fitness i can have a
really hard time with a lot of
inflammation and things and so
it's very common that people get injured
when they play guitars it's a very
athletic
activity actually so the first thing is
take it very seriously
in short i think i'll do a video about
this at some point but in short
always stretch before you play always
take breaks when you play so you know
don't sit down for three hours and play
without taking a break take a break
every 50 minutes or an hour or so
and search for any excess tension in
your playing maybe
for this you might need a teacher to see
if perhaps your
your hands are contorted in any way or
maybe even your posture is contorted
causing tension and then you do that
repeated
tense activity like a thousand times
when you pluck a string
and that can lead to inflammation so
breaks
stretching all those things are good
find a teacher to help you get through
it
jorge writes can you record us an
audiobook with that sweet sweet
sexy voice of yours sure thing hori
no problem che writes have you ever
composed or wished to compose
music good question
i have composed especially when i was
playing in
rock bands and things and i wrote some
songs um
but you know actually when i became a
classical musician i sort of
stopped trying to compose i got so
interested
in playing you know works by
incredible um geniuses um that
i i kind of thought that you know my
compositions didn't really
add up so you know i spent a lot of
years um
just being obsessed with what other
people had uh written
and playing a lot of their music and
being obsessed with trying to understand
you know um bach and chopin and
targa and all these amazing musical
minds
but i have written a few things and uh
maybe one of these days on the channel
i'll be
brave enough to share it with you guys
okay brody norris writes
what is one thing you wish you knew as a
beginner
a lot of things i wish i knew how to
practice
um and if i could go back in time and
help myself with one musical
concept it would be how to use my time
really efficiently
if i could go back in time and teach my
former self
one musical concept it would be how to
practice
uh how to use my time efficiently you
know
and so if you feel like you don't know
how to practice by the way uh i did a
video
uh covering the five common practice
mistakes
that really was mostly about my common
uh practice mistakes but
uh i hope you might find that useful
this is an important one brendonios
writes what was starting classical
guitar like for you
do you have tips for guitars
transitioning to classical guitar
definitely you know i think that
maybe one of the number one barriers
when people want to start
classical guitar if they play you know
folk or rock or something
is that uh generally you you read from
score
musical score when you play classical
and if you can't do that which most
other guitar styles don't um then
well how can you get to the music and
people think of
guitar tab as cheating but actually if
you've watched my videos you'll know
that
tab was the dominant type of notation
for plot instruments for hundreds of
years and it's only since the 1800s
that guitarists adopted violin like
notation in the treble clef
to play its music so there's nothing
wrong with tab
um i would say and i i think that
nowadays
google any classical world's hard piece
and you'll find you know a dozen
versions
in guitar tab and like i did when i had
to audition at college
i couldn't read music well enough but my
my fingers could move i had enough
facility to play
some of the music kind of and what's
important is that you play the music get
your fingers
there start making those sounds and that
the sounds you hear
coming out of your guitar that you're
making you know you're this human
jukebox at that point
you're going to hear these sounds that
are so beautiful and
i made that sound and that's so
inspiring
that's what keeps you going um you know
not playing
a c major scale for three hours a day
there's nothing wrong with playing c
major scales you should also play your
scales that's very important to
build the technique to play as well but
that's not the end goal
right so learn tab
learn by ear whatever it's the fastest
thing for you to get to playing
i would say make sure you just go there
as fast as you can and then you'll
you'll catch up on score reading like i
did
later musical crusader writes whenever
you play do you actually get
lost in the melody uh what i mean is do
you get in the zone when you play
absolutely you know when i do really
poorly in performance is because i'm not
in the zone and i'm not lost in the
music
i'm thinking about you know i'm
distracted i'm thinking about
oh are they judging me do they think i
oh i can't believe he
missed that note or i'm thinking i'm
gonna miss the note or
you know some um some sort of stage
fright uh
mentality and uh i think to perform well
often means
to just you know get lost in the music
you're still in control
you're very much you know what you're
doing and you trust
all the hours of practice you put in but
in the actual moment
the best performing i've ever done i've
sort of transcended all of that and just
let go and just it's like you're in this
you know
timeless right brain space
of pure emotive um
feelings uh and then you just sort of
let go and and
and express these emotions and it's a
beautiful thing and you sort of
you finish and it's as if you know the
time
went by like that an hour-long solar
recital can go by
so fast because you just get in the zone
or it can take
an eternity because you never get in the
zone and you're just worried about
making mistakes
and so you're always i'm always
struggling to
you know make sure i get in the zone
okay milo writes
who is your favorite romantic period
composer and what's your favorite
symphony
um that's tough i i really have an
affinity for romantic
music um i think for me baroque music
and 19th century romantic music are just
like for some reason they just sort of
uh hit me right in the fields so like
uh i would say that in the romantic
period i have a real soft spot for
schubert
um the the poetry
the early the early um german romantic
poetry that he sets by hoti
and schiller and goethe of course is so
beautiful and then how he sets it
is just unreal not to mention that
schubert played guitar
and actually published some of his songs
originally
for guitar and voice and so i've been to
schubert's house in vienna
and that was sort of a quasi-religious
experience it was very cool
so schubert is probably one of my
favorites and then in terms of
symphonies
uh i think mahler symphonies are on just
amazing of course mahler five
but also to this day if i ever want to
just like shed
tears from listening to music listen to
the last
10 minutes of mahler 2 symphony 2
and there's this one video on youtube of
leonard bernstein conducting the end
you know from heart he knows everybody's
part and he's just
so oh my god it's it's incredible just
search
mahler to um ending and it's just
like it'll make you cry every time
aha tyler jackson writes is it ever
appropriate to use rubato when
performing a work by j.s bach
yes roboto is the art of bending time so
if you see
rhythms that look like they're very
quantifiably you know one and two and
three
four are you able to bend them you know
speed up and slow down
absolutely it's just you know you have
to know which style you're in
and how much or maybe how to do this in
fact one type of roboto in
baroque music in general so bach is not
not a special composer in terms of
the style he's writing in within those
stylistic parameters of baroque music
so for example one type of roboto in the
broke period is inequal where you see uh
in typically in the french style you see
one and two
and three and and that can become one
and two and three
and and so that's a type of roboto
actually you're stealing time
and then rushing through it and
generally in larger phrases
yes you can do it it's just not quite
the same type of roboto
as you get in say the 19th century with
piano works by japan
all right well i could just keep reading
these all day thank you guys so much for
all your really good questions
so for the ones that i didn't get to i'm
going to try my best to go through and
answer as many of them as i can
by just replying to your comments thank
you all for
being interested in my channel and for
helping me again to get to
300 000 subscribers i'm really grateful
for all of you
until next time see ya
you